Alice I see you smiling from year to
year you're definitely very happy this
was a tough match you were putting a lot
of pressure with the white pieces but
she was returning the favor as well
putting a lot of pressure early on with
the white pieces sum it up for us this
match
um yeah so the first game I thought it
went pretty well I wasn't expecting
expecting her opening but
I bought a handle into it not the best
but it was enough and then later I had
this nice Queen taxi 5 tactic the second
game
um she played this opening line with G4
which is very aggressive but um playing
for a win and I think it was definitely
a good opening for that but and I wasn't
prepared so I think she was able to win
very nicely in that game
um for the replica I'm actually really
glad that I got black first because
um it's after I won that game of course
it wasn't easy but it felt like we were
both we don't specifically play for a
winner specifically play for a draw and
I thought it was easier to be black
first and then after I was able to win
this game it was a bit different but
that was not an easy game she was really
pressuring you but you did make some
switches early on in the opening did you
discuss with your coach in between the
games did you come prepared to uh with a
different weapon yeah so I thought that
she might try a G4 weapon again because
of course it's a good I'll need to play
for a win and it worked out well for her
um so I I prepared in between around uh
this
um B6 line and it sort of transposes
into a semi-slaw with like Bishop E2
Queen C2 castles and
um I think that's also a line it was a
bit different for me because I played
Rook C8 because I didn't want to cast on
toasty cathode so I'm not sure what how
much that changed the opening but I sort
of knew the plans but I did feel like my
position was worse at some point it was
yes but you did find this very nice idea
and I have to point it out to you I
really like this move Knight to B4 oh
yeah just looking like you're giving
away the Knight but you're actually just
hunting the queen now yeah I thought
that I I really liked that move because
um
uh it's not easy for her she had a low
Time To Save the Queen she played Bishop
A4 which was the best movie eight
um did you see this move Rook to A8 from
the get-go when he played night before
no I missed Bishop A4
um but yeah here
um I guess yeah she can play Bishops C3
and then it's hard but it's already
quite difficult for her as well and it's
very tempting to sacrifice the queen and
it looks like you have this very
dangerous b or a pawn and it seems like
you have enough compensation yeah I was
pretty happy because I thought of these
Queen five five ideas and it's not easy
for
you for and yeah after this I think to
win and this is already I was happy that
I got white in the uh the next games
instead of having to like play for the
defense yeah yeah
um and this game was the first game was
off also like pretty chaotic so uh and
the second came I felt like I probably
played a little bit too passively in the
opening but
um after we turned into the end game I
was pretty happy with the idea I found
um I was up a pond so then I played C30
um once you caught The Rook on C4 it
felt like it was pretty much game over
and you smoothly went on to convert your
advantage tomorrow you will be facing uh
Irina Crush once again you faced her in
the finals you faced her in the finals
of the Champions bracket as well was
going to uh happen tomorrow how are you
going to take her down
um I'm not sure oh obviously I think
last match it was okay for the classical
portion
um but she did beat me in the rapid
playoffs so I'll probably have to make
some adjustments in my general strategy
but for now I'm not sure I was mostly
just focusing on on this match and it's
good that I was able to win this one
guys our congratulations Alice go get
some rest and good luck tomorrow thank
you absolutely wow another great game
and another great day of American Cup
knockout I know